that
police officer made the decision they
had to make and it
it that's fine but it still can be
questioned okay
and that's that's fair enough again i'm
i'm not
i'm not you don't have i don't feel you
have any expectation of
just having no decision made on
anything you do okay fair enough
particularly if you're a government
employee okay
what is the distinction between a
government employee and a private
employee
there's more responsibility okay
for a government employee okay
um
one of the statements is i do not trust
the police
and you circled strongly disagree
so you trust the police i do
i do
you were asked a series of questions
about both the black lives matter
could i go back to that for a second of
course i do trust the police
but part of the reason i press police
just because i know their checks
their checks to what they do and i trust
those checks
i trust i have faith in the system
okay and and i would there are some
other questions
about that i'm going to ask you because
okay okay
and i really appreciate that okay
so you were asked a couple of questions
about the black lives matter
uh whether it's movement or organization
or one
one or the other as well as blue lives
matter
organization and or movement right right
yeah okay and you have a very
favorable view of the black lives matter
and you write that it carries on the
tradition of civil rights activists
of the past and their struggle that's my
perception yeah
and you could you continue to hold that
belief i do
i don't i'm ashamed to say i don't know
enough about it though okay i'm not yeah
not involved in it and
with respect to blue lives matter you
had a somewhat unfavorable opinion of
them
and you wrote i don't understand how
anyone could view the police
blue lives as somehow threatened or
endangered
when they are well armed and have all
the power in most situations
i'm baffled by it
yeah i'd say suspicious so
i guess i just yeah okay
config i just didn't compute from here
okay
um you uh have a background in history
um you
i think you're uh that might be
overstating it
you have a degree in history yeah okay
um
you have a lawyer in your family who
actually lives
you share something with me yeah that's
my
yeah relative my wife yeah
okay um she no longer practices love no
no okay um
would you if you were to serve in it as
a juror in this case would you
knock on the door and ask to talk about
the law about her
[Music]
i wish i could i came so close to
telling her
i i just stopped myself
because i read that last sentence or
whatever yeah
i'd love to talk to her about it but
yeah i'm not going to
your uh your father was a a physician
right
yes um and your ph is a nurse
yes okay so if there were to be medical
evidence
presented in this case would you
i don't know i i may put my foot in my
mouth but it's your father still alive
no oh he passed away i'm sorry so
with with your wife if there's medical
evidence
and you're trying to think i don't
understand how this works would you go
home at night and ask her about
it would be tempting all right
i don't think i would no okay can you
promise us you won't
i can promise you that one yeah it would
so i'll get just a few more questions
for you sir
and i really appreciate again your time
the last couple of questions i have are
on your
opinions regarding the justice system
generally
and you were asked a question do you
believe that the jury system in this
country is fair why
or why not and you write although no
system is infallible
when it comes to making a judgment as
consequential as denying someone his or
her freedom
i believe that being tried before twelve
of your peers
provides a fairness that wouldn't be
there without a jury
good answer i said i amaze myself
um explain like what's the difference
between no jury and a jury
like why do you see that as such a
benefit
i i have to admit i weak on
on the law i'm weak on this subject so
even since i wrote that i've learned
more about
i don't think i even knew it had to be
unanimous when i wrote that or
i mean i'm i'm kind of picking up things
about
um so what's your question again
i just was wondering what do you think
the benefit of having a jury
over just having the judge decide right
yeah not i don't want to put down judges
um
it's just that independence from
from the government um from
just this independent entity
right that doesn't belong to
the police department or to the account
they're just
it's an independent i think that's
fair enough what's what i'd say okay
so again i just i want to read to you
two of your responses again and then
kind of circle back on some stuff
so again it asks the question was
under our system of justice defendants
are presumed innocent of the criminal
charges against them
yeah would you have difficulty following
this principle of law
and your response again was in a case
with as much publicity as this case it
is difficult
yeah based upon the visual evidence i
have seen yeah
i haven't presumed the defendant no
is innocent right but i know i have only
seen and read a small fraction of what
occurred
knowing this i believe i can presume
innocence
until all facts are presented to the
jury okay
so i want you to think about that i'm
going to read you another one of your
responses
okay the question was do you want to
serve as a juror in this case
and you said yes yes and you said
it asks why do you feel that way about
serving as a juror in this case
and you wrote i am marking yes because i
want to look in the mirror every morning
and know the person looking back at me
wasn't afraid to do the right thing when
called upon
that's right i believe i would make a
good juror for many reasons but i will
leave it up to others
and you kind of go on from there i mean
not
much i can read the rest if you want no
no
so it strikes me sir that you
have taken your obligation as a
potential juror
remarkably seriously i'm telling you
and you i think you've reflected right
so you you've acknowledged that once you
saw that
the bystander video right you did not
presume mr chauvin
innocent right no
i mean i was yeah right so you you
didn't
presume him innocent and also you have
some very
strongly held opinions which again
it's your right to have those opinions
and i may agree or disagree with some of
them
yeah the point being is
is that in view of your personal beliefs
right
you've acknowledged that you didn't
presume mr chauvin innocent
and you have concern
about doing the right thing when called
upon
are you the wreck can you honestly say
to us
i can put all of these things aside i
can follow the law
i can listen to the evidence i can apply
the evidence to the law
and make a decision can you do that
it free from all of your other opinions
yeah i that last question about
the la what's the most difficult one
and i've thought about a lot and
you know i did i didn't spy i don't
aspire to be on the jury that was not my
it's not a goal or dream of mine
but i i wanted to what i wrote what i
want to say
i know this is isn't answering your last
question but
it's
my willingness to do it shouldn't be a
factor in deciding if i don't
i i'm willing to do i'm totally willing
to i
i um so that's getting that but that's
not the important part
the important part is do i think i could
do it
and i i
i do think i can do it okay so
thinking you can do it and knowing you
can do it are two different things
you're right right you're right you know
that's true
so if you're sitting here and you're
listening to the to the
to uh the evidence right and
you've already you know you've already
had your opinion influenced by what
you've seen in the past
do you think it may affect your opinions
about
all of these things we've talked about
may harm my client
because you're you're focusing on your
opinion about
police reform or defend you know
defunding the police
will you look at the evidence as a blank
slate
you know i i respect that i respect you
i
yeah i i take this very seriously
and i
i really think the answer is yes i could
if you
[Music]
do your job well and you show me
evidence i would
i definitely that first that thing is
when i'm yeah but i don't have to show
you evidence
oh or now you and whatever if i see that
i'm sorry but
[Music]
your problem is seeing that video
right i mean you you form such a strong
opinion based on that video
that it is really um
cascading through the rest of your
answers
i think that anyone who saw that video
had a reaction
okay right i mean
um and i know we all
want to be fair right we want to be to
say that we're going to be a good
jerk but again i don't know no
that's right you don't know
and we need to be certain of it
absolutely
absolutely so i'll just ask you one last
time
can you
i can even though it pains me i can
fair enough if i may have a moment here
all right so um sir
if you were to ultimately find
a not guilty verdict
how do you think that would affect
well how do i phrase this
your your your wife and you share some
views right
could you go home after finding a not
guilty verdict
and how would you how could you explain
that to your wife
i absolutely could yeah you could yes
yes all right no further questions we'll
exercise the parent career
briefly
all right juror 39 we're going to excuse
you from this case
and so you can the deputy will collect
some of the material from you and then
you'll be released
you have no further jury service on this
trip okay thank you and hold off
bringing anybody else in
all right we're outside the presence of
the juror the
defense made peremptory challenge the
state followed with a batson challenge
and stated maybe mr schlesher you can
make a record of what your
offer was which i found was not a prima
facie showing
thank you very much your honor the state
did as the court indicated issue a
batson challenge to the defense's
preparatory challenge of juror number 39
the articulated basis for the batson
challenge
is that the prospective juror identifies
as hispanic
we believe that the prospective juror
stated an unequivocal
ability to follow the law follow the
court's instructions to presume essence
and not express any views that would
were outside of
what other seated jurors have expressed
all right i would note uh first of all
that you're
telling the court the standard for a
challenge for cause
this is not a challenge for cause
i don't find that this was race-based it
was
this juror was very torn you could tell
and he had difficulty coming to
ultimately
what i think mr uh nelson was trying to
get to was a challenge for cause that he
could not
presume innocence it was difficult for
him to get there it was difficult for
him to
get beyond the videotape because he
likened it unlike any other
potential juror to a world war
ii occupation for his wife has
engaged in uh went with protests
that does not by itself he did not
participate
so that's not a significant factor but i
can see why the close relationship with
somebody who is
deeply involved and his opinions
regarding
the defendant has expressed in the
questionnaire
give the defense a
race neutral reason for their strike and
i don't think the state
has made a private facial case i would
notice note for the record
that we have six jurors so far uh they
identify as follows in from the jury
records
one is multiracial three are white
one is hispanic and one is black
so i don't i see no pattern whatsoever
from the defense of striking
uh racial minorities so i i don't think
that supports the state's
challenge either so that's crits really
we'll bring in the next year
thank you
all right number forty
let's take that up
and you are juror number 40 is that
correct i am all right
a couple things before i turn you over
the attorneys for questioning first of
all
i'm going to swear you in so that all
your answers are under oath so if you
could raise your right hand
you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that you will truthfully answer
all
questions about your qualifications to
serve as a juror
thank you all right thank you
first thing i'm going to do is ask you
uh about the questionnaire you filled
out a questionnaire thank you for taking
the time to do that
uh is there anything as you sit here
right now since it's been several months
that you think you would change or add
to
or even some opinions that you might
change because perhaps your opinion has
evolved over the last few months i i
don't think so
uh although i was kind of trying to
remember the questionnaire and my
answers and
okay it's been a while i'm going to pull
up just a little sorry
great and also uh we are exercising
covert precautions
uh i'm going to keep my mask on we have
plexiglass between us
and you also have plexiglass between you
and the attorneys
so i do allow in the circumstance if you
would like to take off your mask
but i leave it to you um sometimes the
mask makes it a little harder to
understand people but
i leave it to your discretion as far as
keeping it on or off
okay um any changes or additions to the
questionnaire that you're aware of
not that i can think of no and again um
it's been a long time
the attorneys might point to specific
answers you gave because i assume you
didn't keep a copy of your questionnaire
so to refresh your memory they may go to
a question and read it over
including your answer um if your answer
today is different don't worry about it
um we want what we want more than
anything is your honest candid answers
uh to the questions okay also the
questionnaire advise you not to read any
articles or pay attention to any media
but we realize that in the months since
then
inadvertently you may have come across
some information you see a headline
or a friend uh talks to you about the
case and
we told you don't tell anybody your jury
so you can't exactly stop them
anything like that happen to you that
added to your knowledge of the case
um i would say not that added to my
knowledge no
okay anything about the facts of the
case or the participants or pre-trial
matters that have been
litigated anything like that no okay
the whole point of this is there's a
variety of things that you know about
the case
and you may inform certain opinions
about the case
dude and we want to make sure that if
you
sit as a juror you decide this case only
on the evidence
and on the law that i give you and that
you put aside
anything you know about the case put
aside any opinions about the case
and just take the evidence as it comes
do you think you could do that i i do
yeah
you've given a long list of uh witnesses
did you recognize anybody on the list um
you know there's one
name uh kind of a common
name um so david elm
as might have been a i think it was a
student maybe years ago
okay um i'm not sure that person's uh
participation in the case but if that
person appears
how long ago was this person a student
uh 10 years ago okay
whatever their occupation is or whatever
their role in this case
do you think that would affect your
ability to weigh them uh
dispassionately and neutrally no because
i i really don't i
recognize the name but i don't really
remember the person very much
okay and so you could treat them like
any other witness as far as
weighing their credibility absolutely
okay
now we've also had an estimate of trial
length would be
if you were on this jury we would excuse
you and you could go about your business
until march 29th
and then come back we would start trial
we anticipate four weeks
and i think you may have indicated some
concern
the length of trial so a teacher i'm
concerned about my
students but i had made arrangements for
substitutes as needed so
okay so you could make it work yes okay
uh do you have any questions for me
before i turn you over to the attorneys
not that i think that's all right with
that uh
regarding juror number 40 mr nelson you
may inquire
good afternoon sir good afternoon so
um that microphone unfortunately doesn't
pull
uh closer to you so i think you're gonna
move in all right
and with your mask on it's fine to keep
it on but obviously um
makes a little bit more difficult to see
to hear excuse me
um so what i'm going to do sir is i'm
going to ask you
a series of some kind of general
questions first
and then from there i'd like to ask you
some specific questions about
some answers in your questionnaire okay
okay now i know it was a long time ago
um and you probably haven't read it you
didn't keep a copy
right nobody's trying to trick you we're
just gonna
we'll read it to you refresh your
recollection a little okay all right
so first question i have is um
if you and i were to meet in some social
circumstance whether it be a party or an
event of some sort
what are a few things that you would
want me to know or what are a few things
i would
learn about you in that conversation
[Music]
i'm a husband and dad
i'm a teacher um
i love singing in my church choir
with my wife musician
okay are you a musician in
ways other than with your voice you play
instruments
um i don't play instruments i'm a singer
and a music teacher
okay perfect and
you it's my understanding of the process
that at some point you received a letter
in the mail
that said you were going to be summoned
for jury duty that was the first
uh sort of notification right when you
when you received that first
notification what was your
first reaction oh my
okay um why um
well i mean i i know that it's a case
that
has a it's a large magnitude um
and it's uh
honestly a little nerve-wracking um
but i gave it some thought and
uh recognized it as my duty to
try to serve jury duty as needed okay
and so you um you had that thought when
you learned that it was this particular
case
right because is that when you learned
it was this particular case when you got
this big questionnaire in the mail
uh i think that's what yeah there's a
question there right
right okay and how did you feel
uh today when you got here to the
government center
um a little nervous i can stand up and
sing in front of a group of people and
be comfortable
but talking in front of uh people and
stuff is nerve-wracking
sure fair enough um
i assure you i don't want to trade roles
with you
i don't think you'd appreciate that um
the the uh but the security and the
fortifications you said that made you
kind of nervous or just being
in this room i guess um i know the
process more
actually the security made me uh that
felt good
okay yeah so you you because i know
you've expressed some concerns about
anonymity and things of that nature in
your questionnaire
and so you were you were concerned
about it and seeing those preparations
made you feel safe
that's correct okay um and then
ultimately
this afternoon when the judge kind of
gave us the instructions or gave you the
instructions about
how we're doing everything we can to
maintain your anonymity at this point
how did that make you feel
um i mean good i i
i still have a little bit of concern
about you know after the trial of name
you know what our names are released
okay um i know
sometimes they're not i don't know how
that works but
okay so at some point they may be though
too right we don't know what the future
will hold but at some point they may be
um why does that make you nervous
um i mean it can potentially
draw some unwanted attention i don't
know
are you thinking more in terms of
harassment or potential harassment or
are you thinking more in terms of
physical safety like
violence that could be visited upon you
i'm
i guess i'm just thinking in terms of
people
wanting information and that kind of
thing okay
so no concerns for your physical safety
just more concerns you just
kind of want to be anonymous
yeah i would say my wife has more
concerns about physical
volcanic safeties but yeah so you i mean
perfectly natural you've talked about
this with your wife right yes
and you said she has some more concerns
about your physical safety
yeah do you think that's um justified on
her part
um i mean i've tried to
convince her that i don't think that
that's a probability or
an issue okay have you been successful
in your
convincing um i
i guess uh that's fine i wouldn't say
the jury's still out
okay um
well let me ask you just some kind of
other general questions can you think of
a situation in your life
where you have been called upon called
upon
to resolve a dispute between two people
sure okay now just thinking about that
in your mind
without any real details how did you
approach that situation
and what did you do to try to resolve
that dispute
i'm thinking of some students
and so brought them together
and actually first heard kind of each of
their
stories from their own perspective and
then brought them together and
i encouraged to talk through and get out
in terms of being a juror right i mean
this is in some
some regard part of what your job would
be
as you analyzed the evidence in the case
disputes may arise
right in the jury room a piece of
evidence
made to one juror seem to be very
important
and not to another right sure so in that
jury room
there may be disputes and ultimately
that's what this case is about too right
it's a dispute
there's two different perspectives or
two sides of the story so
what tools would you bring as a juror in
those two scenarios both in terms of
resolving disputes among jurors
as well as analyzing the evidence and
that's a really long complicated
question and i'm sorry
um i mean i guess i have a pretty calm
demeanor and can try to encourage people
to
listen to each other and try to explain
their
points of view to the best extent
possible okay do you think that there
are things
in terms of the the analysis of the
evidence how would you
resolve a dispute over evidence
right thank you
um i i guess
i'm not sure okay well let's let me try
to give you a
simple hypothetical say that there is
some piece of
evidence and i don't we'll just pick a
number a lab report
right and you're looking at this
lab report and you're saying i think
that this is a really important piece of
information
but somebody else goes that's nonsense
we don't need to worry about that
right how do you you know something
that's important to you
is not important to someone else how do
you resolve that
kind of make a list of pros and cons as
to why it's valuable
and why it seems important
okay and in terms of
um you understand
that a jury decision in this type of a
case has to be unanimous
that's a yes yes um
and that means all 12 people have to
agree
right right so if you are looking at
this piece of evidence
right and the majority of the group is
saying
ignore it ignore it quit it's not
important it's not important
are you the type of person that would
just simply kind of follow along with
everyone else
or would you say no i this is really
important and you need to hear me and
speak your mind
probably the latter okay the you're
gonna hear my opinion type of a guy
yeah yes okay
now um can you think of a situation in
your personal life where you've had to
decide between two stories which person
is telling the truth about a story
[Music]
i'm not coming up with anything
specifically right now sure
you have some uh grown children right
yes
and at some point in their their
adolescence or young adulthood
um perhaps your children
[Music]
had two very different stories about
something that happened
um actually i
i can't think of any circumstances like
that all right well that might be my
perspective might have been different
than theirs
okay um well let's let's just kind of
take it in the hypothetical event um how
do you tell if someone is telling the
truth
um i mean you listen to what they're
saying
you pay attention to how they're doing
it
um if there's other people that can
corroborate um
that all comes into play okay so
now let's take it in a little broader
lens
what two people are looking two
witnesses are looking at that same
store that same incident right that same
thing they're watching it happen
they're standing right next to each
other and one of them says
this is what happened and the other says
this is what happened
right how do you and they're nowhere
close to each other
how do you reconcile the same process or
um
yeah i mean i i think they just have to
kind of keep it trying to find new ways
to express what they're
uh seeing and see if they can
come to some sort of understanding that
they can both agree upon
okay can you think of a circumstance in
your life either personally or
professionally where you were a
100 percent convinced of something and
it later turned out you were wrong
i'm sure it happened okay um
are you the type of person who can
reflect back
and say i made a mistake i'm going to
learn from it
or are you kind of the person that
brushes it aside and
oh no definitely i've learned a lot from
mistakes
great so i'm going to ask you um a
series of questions about your responses
and again
i'll read you what you wrote um so no
no no tricks afflict here okay
um the first question that you're asked
in the questionnaire is
what you remember seeing about this
incident in either the media or in
conversation
your general knowledge about this
particular case
okay now before i go down this path i
want to make sure that we're all on the
same page
a video you may describe this video
was taken by a bystander that video was
uploaded to
a social media platform went viral and
became news
right yes have you seen that video
yes okay um and i think you said you've
seen it
six or more times i'm guessing that's
about right yeah
okay um and i guess my question is is
in that six or more times when you
learned of this video did you go on to a
social media platform or some other
website and watch the video from start
to finish
or are you are you referring to smaller
clips and
segments i mean the first few times i
think it was just the smaller
clips and then there was one time where
i saw a longer
segment okay like um
have you seen any other videos of this
incident that have been made publicly
available um i sort of
i feel like there was one that was like
from an
angle um
yeah okay do you remember
do you remember seeing any like body
cameras for police officers or security
footage or anything of that name i'm
sorry that's what i'm not sure
what the other angle was okay that's
fair enough
but but so um this longer video that you
watched
um
you watched that more than six times or
was that just once
no just once yeah okay
and so i'm gonna ask you you you wrote
kind of a long
you know you tried to remember
everything that you had heard
about this case and um
[Music]
you you had a lot more than just this
incident
right about the people involved and all
of that
so are you a fairly regular consumer of
the news yeah
um by television newspaper
um so npr
and we get the newspaper and we watch
the news pretty regularly yeah okay
um
so you you wrote a little bit about
um the charges initially or what you
recalled to be the charges right
and then you recall reading some article
that mr floyd and mr
shelvin had worked together in some
location
right um and you also heard
that mr floyd didn't want to get into
the squad car because he was
claustrophobic
right
you also recall hearing something about
conflicting autopsy reports
as to whether floyd had drugs in his
system
um well i don't know if it was about
that or if it was just
kind of different conclusions and i
don't remember exactly what those were
okay and then you recall reading
um some information about mr shelvin's
personal like divorce and
some other things he has going on right
yes so
you have and you're probably one of the
few people that kind of went beyond
just this incident last year in may
right and i just kind of wanted to ask
you some questions about that
do you understand that in this trial
evidence will be presented in this
courtroom
right yes and some of the
things that you reference in here
obviously you've heard about them you've
read about these
things uh
that may not be evidence in this case
yeah i understand
okay can you set those things that
you've heard
in the news aside
and judge the case on the evidence in
the courtroom
you already have to kind of take it with
me
what do you mean what do you mean taking
the greatness
well i mean when there's ongoing
investigations
and information coming forth as
information comes out
later it may not be accurate
um the
question asked you from what you have
seen read
or heard do you have a general
impression of the defendant
to which your response or that what you
chose was very negative
and when asked you feel away
you wrote seeing the look on sherman's
face in video
and seeing the other officers and him
ignoring
pleas of bystanders to stop once he was
on the ground and subdued
yeah that was difficult okay um
why was that difficult
um when you see somebody who is
already subdued it seemed very
unnecessary and
over the top to me
you mentioned kind of earlier in terms
of
dispute resolution is the importance of
hearing both sides
right would you agree that there's
probably more information
that will come out in this courtroom not
and some of that information will be
relevant to
perhaps police training or
other aspects of of law enforcement
that make shape would you be willing to
allow that information to change your
initial perception
um yeah i mean if that potentially sure
okay well you understand again mr
chauvin is presumed innocent of these
charges
and you formed and it's perf you're not
the first person to come in here
and have a negative opinion of the case
right
so again it's perfectly acceptable
they're your views and you're entitled
to hold your views
the question is can you set aside your
views
and judge this case on the evidence
and the law as it's presented in court
yes i think you can right so you think
you can or you can
there's a difference uh yes i can
okay
you have uh the question was asked of
you of your
impression of mr floyd you
checked it was neutral and you said i
don't know much about him besides what i
saw in the video
i understand he has a record and he may
have tried to buy something at cup foods
with possibly a fake bill but he
shouldn't have been treated that way for
that
right yeah so again
can you at least acknowledge that you
formed a
your impression about mr floyd
is certainly in response to how you
viewed he was treated
by the minneapolis police officers to
the well
based on what i saw on the video and
such yeah okay
[Music]
you were asked if you've talked about mr
floyd's death with your family
friends or co-workers co-workers or
discuss it online
for example on social media and you
check yes
and it was asked if yes what opinions
have you expressed
you wrote floyd had a record but didn't
deserve to die by the
by die from this by a cop who is
supposed to serve and protect
who ignored his pleas that he couldn't
breathe chauvin should have
stopped the other officers should have
intervened
as i think one truck and maybe it goes
on
that was the end as i think what was the
last part
i think one tried oh right
okay so i guess my
again you have formed a very strong
opinion
agreed yeah right
you've expressed it kind of in three
different ways
in response to three different questions
right
[Music]
is that i'm sorry it's okay um
and are you convinced that you can set
aside your very strong opinions
presume mr chauvin innocent
and analyze this case on the facts and
evidences presented in court
yes because i think you have to approach
it with a blank slate and start all over
so you were asked a question about um
[Music]
the protests that occurred after uh the
death of mr floyd
uh you wrote that the protests
solidified people around the need
for change in our police and our society
system
systemic racism the vandalism
by boogaloo boys and others was very
distressing
yes okay and you underlined the word
need in your sentence solidified people
around the need
for change in our police yes
so you have a an opinion about mr
chauvin
right again nothing wrong with that
and you also have a pretty strong
opinion that there needs to be
change or police reform
yes i mean i think that's even been
noted by the
uh the head of the police okay
sir i'm going to ask you to go back to
the courtroom the deputy will direct you
we'll be on break until 3 30.
thank you
you